tom freston I grew up in Connecticut
suburban Connecticut and a very
homogeneous small typical suburban town
father was a commuter and I guess it
shaped me in the sense that it was such
a homogeneous place that when i was 17 I
sort of went off to college and never
really came back and just sort of kept
going it was sort of an idyllic
childhood in many ways nice place to
grow up but somewhat limiting in its
diversity had access to new york city
which was nice but i would say that i
found the place a bit stifling overall
maybe one of the biggest influence was
always my peers you know learned a lot
from my peers and kind of grew up with
the early days of television and was
quite influenced by the media as well
you know picking up signals from
wherever I could get them well my hope
was that I would be in some type of
creative profession although I really
took me a while to figure out what that
could be I grew up in a place where most
most people most males who worked it was
a sort of a traditional neighborhood you
know we're businessmen so I always
imagined myself as some kind of
businessman but creative businessman not
necessarily a doctor or a lawyer and
some kind of professional craft
you